[Música]
me están temblando las piernas un poco
no sé si hay algo en el break mega
showman
le gustaría aprender el secreto para
tomar imágenes impactantes
bueno
vengo a contar mi cosmovisión sobre la
empatía muchos de ustedes conocen lo que
es la empatía pero pocos le aplican
la
la empatía es percibir comprender lo que
puede sentir a otra persona en palabras
simples es ponerse en los pies
de otra persona pero desde mí
profesión es un poco más es mirar a
través de los ojos del otro
como por ejemplo en esta imagen donde yo
puedo ver el amor que tiene una abuela
por su nieto me imagino que muchos
pueden identificarse con esta imagen con
algún familiar de ustedes y sentir el
amor que tienen con esa persona
a través de los años en esta profesión
me di cuenta el poder que tienen las
palabras las palabras positivas
construyen y las palabras negativas de
distribución
entonces usted se preguntarán
como hice esta fotografía como llegué a
hacer esta fotografía
dos horas y media caminando para subir a
una montaña en ushuaia y que los novios
tengan esa imagen muchos de ustedes
dirán yo ni loco
pero creo que a través de mi fotografía
que es capturar momentos sentimientos y
que queden congelados en el tiempo puedo
convencer a un montón de personas que se
animen a estar frente a mi cámara
congelar un momento
de las hijas en el altar cuando su padre
se están casando
o una pareja de novios bailarines que se
animen a bailar arriba de una garita no
es normal yo generalmente voy por la
garita y no veo gente bailando no
pero por ahí todo eso está en mi
imaginación pero no solamente queda en
mi imaginación sino trato de pasarlo un
poco más allá de mi cámara
a través de las palabras para convencer
a esas personas
imagínense donde estoy yo si yo tuve
esta imagen
nuevo photoshop para que tengan una idea
si me quieren contratar van a salir como
son ustedes
acostado en el agua tranquilo esa es una
sesión para 73 que es una sesión por
fiesta donde los novios están un poco
más relajados y no tienen problemas se
mojan el vestido o el traje
me encanta hacer estas sesiones
y en un momento empecé a compartir
momentos más íntimos con mis clientes y
pedirles si podía viajar en el auto con
ellos hasta la iglesia y captar por
ejemplo este momento donde un padre está
llorando porque no era un buen partido
el novio
no son amigos ya todas estas personas
terminan siendo amigos
llegó a la iglesia y siempre trato de ir
hablando con todos no soy el fotógrafo
que pasa desapercibido sino que
constantemente voy alentando a todos
para que les quieren recuerdo y por
ejemplo en este momento llegando a la
iglesia la novia digo bajó un poco el
vídeo está tu papá y generar ese reflejo
en el espejo y que también en el parante
no sé si ven ahí está la iglesia
entonces ya está contada la historia
lo mío es contar esto y a través de
imágenes otros cuentan cuentos y yo
cuento imágenes con imágenes historias
o ponéis que aparezca un perro muchos
dicen máximo en el auto tenemos muchos
perros porque cada vez que vemos fotos
tuyas hay animales y la verdad que no
pero si tengo alimento entonces la
batalla digo
y por el que te digan que ese perro es
la persona que faltó al casamiento que
la ha sentido identificada por alguien
que no está
entonces cada uno va a identificar la
imagen como quiera
y el que está dentro de la imagen lo va
a tomar con el verdadero sentido que
tienen haciéndole retratos son a una
buena novia en un balcón acá afuera ahí
veo que el padre se empieza a cambiar
entonces género una composición para
guardar los dos momentos y por ahí me
dicen máximo saca fotos para los
clientes para vos o para quién y la
verdad es un conjunto cuenta un poco de
mi historia lo trasladó a través de mi
cámara y a través de la empatía entiendo
un poco de la historia que tienen ellos
que no voy a no quisiera una foto del
padre más en ese momento que se está
preparando para gran día o por el que
las testigos empiezan a contarles
algunas experiencias o palabras a la
novia y se emociones y queda ese momento
de registrado
paul y pasó desapercibido pero porque me
conecto mucho con ellos la hija de la
novia a punto de tirar el vestido y la
abuela diciendo no aguanta que todavía
no se puso ahí ya está planchado
alimento con parejas que no se quieren
mucho
generar esto generar movimientos cosas
que sean diferentes
eso pasa dentro mío lo traslado a partir
de las palabras hacia las personas que
me eligen
por y doy consejos a los novios no
ahí lo entendieron
eso es un cartel de un cartel de la
calle y digo bueno vamos a esperar a que
cuando vuelva a pasar y se imagina
hacemos una foto ellos no entendían nada
y bueno por suerte ya había cobrado la
seña la boda se suspendió
entonces busque hacer eso no empezar a
combinar todos los elementos que tengo
en el ambiente o genera imágenes que
salgan de lo real con un simple reflejo
de un espejo de la torta así me corrió
la ambientador a comisión a dónde está
el espejo de la torta
eso está ahí no hay trucos son fotos
directos pero también me toca empatizar
y ponerme en la piel de algunos novios
porque ustedes ven una simple imagen
pero esta señora que está ahí es la
madre de su mejor amigo y su mejor amigo
tuvo la mala suerte de estar en la
tragedia de cromañón que fue una
tragedia muy grande que sucedió en
buenos aires y murieron muchas personas
entonces capturar ese momento para él
fue muy importante misión me encantaron
todas las fotos especialmente esta yo
conocía un poco la historia yo me metí
en la historia de ellos y no me hubiera
metido tanto si no si no tengo una
personalidad empática para con ellos
de vuelta generando imágenes que salgan
un poco de lo real y es así donde me
caigo clientes que me gustaría una
imagen que esté de los dos lados pero
que vayamos para aquel lado no
generalmente no me dicen eso está en mi
cabeza le mostré la imagen y no
entienden y bueno está bien yo ya te
pague esa imagen queda dentro del pack y
ya está si me gusta o no
y también pueden decir chase max y cómo
hiciste para obtener esta imagen
soy obstetra no le había comentado
no la idea es poder como les dije
convencer un poco a las personas para
que van a tener para que tengan
recuerdos únicos únicos que no van a
volver en el tiempo
siempre si van a hacer un parto alguna
vez tengan en cuenta que tengan tarjeta
de memoria porque no podemos volver a
hacer esa foto
a veces el poder de la palabra no sirve
mucho con algunos y con otros no los
puedo convencer para tener imágenes no
pero con otros si recuerdan que lo que
es la fotografía de niños es más para
los padres que para los niños el inglés
no tiene nada dice que este tiene un
aparato bueno ahora ya saben un poco más
ahora te sacan el celular ponen la clave
de vídeo de youtube y yo están bailando
pero por ahí es más para los padres lo
que son estas sesiones y tratar de digo
esta foto es bueno de mostrarme no
porque tenés por tu hermano y le dio un
beso yo no le dije darle un beso en el
cachete y voces ratos ojos quiero ver
sentimientos no ellos son espontáneos va
saliendo lo que sea o bueno poder
convencer a una una obvia de que por más
que sea un día de lluvia va a tener
mejor recuerdo imagínense en la mente de
una mujer que se está por casar y está
lloviendo donde uno se imagina mi boda
sol
no sé de dos platos voladores uno se
imagina cualquier cosa y está lloviendo
yo no pasa nada
todas las fotos van a salir con lluvia
pero no pasa nada
entonces buscar eso o también está otra
vez termina la fiesta finalmente todas
las parejas están totalmente
distribuidas o no el que ha ido a una
fiesta depende de que le toque y
convencerlo de cruzarnos al campo
hablado para hacer una foto buscar
recuerdo su único que sé que queden
congelados en el tiempo para quién y
para nosotros una vez pasado el tiempo
al volver a recordar recordar volver
atrás con el corazón o para generaciones
futuras que a lo mejor no pudieron estar
presentes
el encuentro de un padre con su hija
antes de ir a la ceremonia es un momento
muy emotivo la primera vez que la ve
vestida de novia salvo que ella venga
con varios casamientos
este no fue el caso
y esta imagen pueden decir max y si te
encanta el agua max y ya me di cuenta
pero s
es el canal de beagle que en ushuaia en
el sur de argentina
lo que ven ahí al costado ahí
bien ahí es donde el fin congelado así
que imagínense la temperatura del agua
entonces como hago yo para convencer a
los novios que hagan esa imagen me meto
al agua llegó guau parece en las termas
de río hondo
pero no lo expreso con mi cara y los
trato de convencer para que ellos digan
nada bueno si son las termas ahí entran
una vez que entraron ya está la imagen
va a quedar como en este momento si
quedó congelada muchas cosas quedarán
congeladas en este momento
empatizar con los niños como les dije
obtener imágenes donde ellos se olviden
de mí y captar la esencia que tienen
ellos estaban jugando con una simple
herramienta eso es lo que busco a través
de mi fotografía empatizar palabras
positivas para alentarlos a que tengan
recuerdos únicos hoy algunos novios
los ramos ya dice ya me casé ya lo puedo
patear si no ven la patada de novio son
ideas digo te animas a patear el ramo y
bueno ya está y hacemos imágenes o yo
imagino
distintos momentos o convencer niños por
las dudas convencer a la novia que
terminó la fiesta se tenía una pileta en
un hotel que no está permitido meterse a
la pileta no fue idea mía no sé si algún
dueño del hotel acá
pero que quede congelada en ese momento
único para ellos
o bueno en bariloche convencer otros
novios sin éxito sus novios son todos
muy copado mason
todos saltan al agua digo pero se bañan
también
pero no yo creo que los novios me buscan
a mí o las parejas o los padres me
buscan a mí por las imágenes que ven yo
no voy digo si vos me parece que puede
ser mi cliente si más porque tengo que
vendernos
o por ahí me tocan
retratar estas imágenes de abril es una
niña que espera estaba esperando lo que
es un trasplante del corazón
representar la esencia en ella meterme
en su vida fue algo bastante duro para
mí y me sensibilizó un montón imagínense
una niña de nueve años que en un momento
me dice las fotos me gustaría hacerla
para generar una campaña de
concientización para la donación de
órganos y buena mirada sí y si se agarra
los ojos estás viendo una chica de más
de 20 años
entonces cada uno tiene una historia por
eso siempre digo no juzguen a las otras
personas solamente por su apariencia
porque no sabemos lo que han vivido
otros novios estando con el agua abajo
un muelle olas y ello están ahí la idea
es obtener imágenes convencerlos lo
mismo no pasa nada los tiburones se
fueron hasta podemos meternos ese río de
la plata o podido retratar a ellos
lc días 90 años 70 años de novio no se
casaron digo están ilegales tienen diez
hijos
y hortencia 91 haselböck chiquito
imagínense lo que fue interactuar con
ellos para obtener esta imagen no
convencer traten de hacer una foto de
sus abuelos yendo por donde los llevo yo
en el momento digo nos animan a tirarse
de aído en paracaídas para hacer una
imagen
pero bueno es tratar de convencer a los
clientes oa las personas que las fotos
no solamente son clientes ellos por ahí
pasa que en los ex novios se presentan
en el ceremonia
entonces si ven a cada pareja besándose
y ahí apareció el chat
entonces
es buscar capturar momentos
preste en el momento que tenga hacer
silencio
porque así como están las palabras
positivas están las palabras negativas
y hoy en día las palabras negativas los
relacionamos con el llamado bullying o
no
alguien conoce lo que es el bullying es
agredir a una persona por algo que no me
gusta o por algo que no conozco lo
agrego porque no me gusta o no conozco
lo que él es está haciendo
entonces
ahora me gustaría hacer un ejercicio
pero me tienen que hacer caso
vamos a cerrar todos los ojos nos van a
abrir hasta que yo diga
tienes para cerrar todos los ojos
hay algunos que nos cerraron
y voy a decir unas palabras como por
ejemplo flaco esquelético nerz cuerdo
inflan traga nunca vas a hacer a alguien
y quiero que empiecen a reaccionar si en
algún momento de su vida ustedes
sufrieron bullying con algunos de esos o
puede ser otro puede ser a esta agresión
física y me gustaría que levanten bien
alto la mano derecha si en algún momento
sufrieron bullying en su vida puede
levantarla solamente lo estoy viendo ya
todos tienen los ojos cerrados
bueno contarla poder levantarla en este
momento
los ayudantes a cadetes van a pasar a
inspeccionar su billetera de paso
juntamos un poco de dinero
bueno sigan con la mano derecha
levantada y ahora sin abrir los ojos me
gustaría que si en algún momento ustedes
hicieron bullying individual o brutal o
peritaje individual o grupal levanten en
su mano izquierda bien alto
ahora me gustaría que sin bajar los
brazos abran los ojos
espero que todos tengan me sobrante no
por las dudas de este ejercicio y miren
un poco a su alrededor y van a ver que
todos en algún momento o casi todos en
algún momento sufrimos bullying o
hicimos o sea destruimos personas o nos
han destruido
entonces pueden decir bueno pero qué
tiene que ver la empatía al poder la
palabra al bullying a mí personalmente
el bullying es una persona más positiva
y más empática
no todas las personas tienen
un carácter de salir adelante no pueden
superar algunas situaciones y hay niños
jóvenes que toman decisiones drásticas
entonces
me gustaría que cuando ustedes vean
alguna situación de bullying no no se
tapen los ojos
acción en reacciones frente a esas
situaciones porque entre todos si
luchamos para obtener
para que el bullying se reduzca vamos a
poder lograrlo pero si tenemos que
intervenir meternos en esas situaciones
por y me dicen pero bueno pero como se
puede reducir lo que es el bullying por
y solamente hablándole a una persona con
ilusión con cariño y sobre todo con amor
de esa manera podemos empezar a
empatizar con mucho más gente
ahora me gustaría yo soy el de los
ejercicios y ustedes van a salir
transpirando acá
me gustaría que pidan un deseo para un
otro cualquiera
un deseo para otra persona y lo escriban
en un papel esos papeles que tenía ahí
con lapicera así puede ser
vamos a decirlo ahí
yo puedo ir hasta el baño en este
momento bueno
veo que mucho están revisando un poco
los bolsos
ahí
yo también tengo mi papel acá con un
deseo
un deseo para un otro cualquiera que no
lo sé que es por favor que los deseos
sean positivos
si hay alguno negativo que por favor no
ponga el nombre si quieren pueden poner
el nombre y porque ese mensaje lo
valedero otra persona que no sabemos
quién es
escriba te deseo que
o sea feliz deseo que tenga salud lo que
quieran otra persona lo vale
en este momento tengo que bailar para
que pase el tiempo
ya terminaron más o menos tampoco
tampoco un deseo ojalá que
bueno cultivan a tener una hoja saben
todo va a ser un avión
yo le voy a enseñar a hacer un boeing
747 con este papel
no sé si va a alcanzar
pero bueno el que no sabe hacer un avión
no pasa nada se puede retirar de las
obras no hay drama acá no vamos a
discriminar los la idea es que si nunca
hicieron un avión
ojo que este papel tiene un beso de
vanina no es mío el que reciba este
deseo de vanina regrese con manía que es
un papel ahí estamos
bueno lo que vamos a hacer agarrar el
papelito este lo vamos a doblar al medio
aquí no sale hacer aviones no lo vamos a
volver ahí veo que veo muchos que están
haciendo vuelvo a hablar un ángulo por
acá
otro por acá
es más fácil cuando tengo una mesa pero
usted tampoco tiene mesa
estoy enfatizando con ustedes
vamos a crear el avión voy a hablar loca
por favor si pueden no hacer tanto ruido
con los papeles que me distraen
hoy vamos
guau qué avión
y me gustaría que a la cuenta de 3 100
haciendo el avión termine lo haga la
cuenta el que no puedo hacer un avión
que haga un bollito siempre hay aviones
que son de distinta manera
está todo en su imaginación vamos a ver
quién es más ingenioso que otro que la
cuenta de tres vamos a tirar lo que son
los aviones por favor traten de no
sacarle el ojo al de al lado porque no
me hago responsable piénselo entre
ustedes no tienen enseñar yo porque
después sigo de la charla para no
invadir un poco el escenario y me
gustaría que antes que se retiren
de la sala no antes que se retiren de la
sala levanten un papel cada una usted es
un avioncito y se den cuenta el poder
que tienen las palabras
yo pedí el deseo que por favor que el
niño esté que el hijo no pierda los
anillos
esa idea mía que se me ocurren en
lugares donde hay piedra pasto y todo
eso
entonces bueno a la cuenta de tres
vamos a tener el avioncito que se
coordina uno y llegó uno dos tres y los
digamos no
hay 12 está bueno vamos 1 2 3
bueno
hay que dos ya saben cuál es el mío
creo firmemente
así era
creo firmemente que si cambiamos la
forma en que miramos al otro
podemos cambiar el mundo así bueno
gracias a todos
[Aplausos]